foreign
are we out of the pandemic yet what will
be the lasting After Effects and what
are the treatment options for the
physical and mental consequences which
are still impacting the lives of so many
around the world welcome to this week's
covid-19 special
we looked at Kenya where women have
joined together to form savings groups
which also Grant members loans
and we'll be talking to an expert about
the latest medicines that are being
developed to treat SARS cov2
but first we head to Argentina where
many young people developed mental
health problems during the pandemic
[Music]
Lina Brito is a made from Buenos Aires
and mother of two children
the youngest of them 16 started going to
a psychologist last year because he
didn't want to go back to school after
spending 2020 in virtual education due
to the pandemic
I noticed that he was very very
distressed especially at the end of 2020
in the start of 2021
and it was quite an issue until one day
he said to me yes it's fine Mom let's
find a psychologist he didn't want to
talk he lived in anguish he wasn't
getting out of bed
other classmates dropped out of school
but her son continues to attend although
he does Miss most classes
but there are much more serious cases
than those of Carolina's son
Dr Javier Rodriguez Arias is head of
Child and Adolescent Psychiatry at
hospital austral
here in elsewhere in Argentina cases of
miners requiring hospitalization for
mental health problems have increased by
up to 30 percent compared to the period
prior to the pandemic
is
some of the at-risk adolescents
developed psychological symptoms and
stressful situations
that could mean thoughts of suicide and
this requires immediate hospitalization
and medication to modify these disorders
the doctor also warns that consultations
for different emotional problems such as
eating disorders anxiety and depression
have increased by between 30 and 40
percent
there was more demand due to the stress
and isolation adolescence experienced
I'd say they were the most affected age
group since they lost Social contact
it hasn't gone back to normal
precisely because of this stress the
consequences of the confinement began to
be seen
a
the hospital's Children's Mental Health
Team meets up once a week
psychologist and Professor Paz manianini
explains why the biggest problem is
surfaced not during but after the 2020
quarantine
the pandemic situation is a traumatic
one in Social terms the consequences can
only be seen in the medium or long term
the return to the social sphere without
sufficient tools and without training in
children created consequences that we're
only seeing now
before the pandemic Manya Nini saw 20 to
25 patients a week now it's between 35
and 40.
demand has increased in Argentina the
country with the most psychologists for
inhabitant in the world and where going
to therapy is a common ritual not
stigmatized
perhaps the fact that this is n't true
where Consulting a psychologist is seen
as natural means that worse consequences
were prevented in time
given the impact of the pandemic the
Argentine government began a federal
mental health approach strategy in April
according to its director Mariana Moreno
for adolescence it aims to prevent
suicides and problematic eating habits
a
New Life perspectives and healthy
leisure activities in the neighborhoods
anything that Rhymes our quality of life
helps to keep people from contemplating
suicide
but the country's mental health
infrastructure is overwhelmed
we find hospitals clinics and
institutions don't have the necessary
beds to admit these adolescents
Argentina is not alone the UN says that
Global cases of anxiety and depression
have increased by a quarter since the
pandemic
[Music]
and now for the late scientific
discoveries
time on the effects that the coronavirus
can have on the brain
V2 can really mess with your head
and I don't just mean how the pandemic
can drive you up the wall even if it
does that too
a recent study indicates that the
coronavirus might also be able to
directly damage the brain
facting it in ways that could explain
certain long-covet symptoms
autopsies on people who died from the
disease have shown that covid-19 can
trigger inflammation in the brain
indirectly even if the virus itself
isn't detected there but some experts
think South Korea could also play a more
direct role in neurological symptoms
so what would the virus do exactly if it
reached the brain
that was the question at the heart of
the study the researchers tweeted
knowing that the virus was
neuro-invasive we wanted to study how
different cell types of the brain
respond to the viral Invasion we used
neuroimmune brain organoids containing
microglia and modeled live viral
infection brain organoids are often
called mini brains by the Press but they
aren't really brains they are
three-dimensional clumps of culture
tissue made up of the cell types found
in the human brain
so how did these organoids react to
being infected in the lab with sasko V2
spoiler alert not very well
the researchers found that microglia and
astrocytes had distinct responses that
shared features observed in
neurodegenerative diseases and activated
microglia tripled the engulfment of
post-synaptic Termini of neurons say
what
let's break that down a little to get
what the researchers mean you first have
to understand what microglia are
microglia cells are immune cells that
clean up molecular debris in the brain
and go after pathogens that try to
infect it they also support the repair
of damaged neurological tissue at least
they do under normal circumstances
but a direct infection with a sales cov2
is anything but normal
it caused the microglia in the organoids
to kind of flip out the researchers
observe that the immune cells started
destroying structures they once
encouraged to grow
synapses
so instead of helping signal
transmission the microglia started
messing with it
the effect was similar to what
researchers have observed in other
neurodegenerative diseases like
Alzheimer's
so their work provides at least a
hypothetical explanation for why some
long-covet patients experience brain fog
but don't despair just yet if you have
it the good news is that synopsis can
also regenerate
[Music]
our science editor Derek Williams
answers your questions about the latest
research
this week our question comes from an
anonymous viewer
[Music]
might melting glaciers release pathogens
that could cause future pandemics
[Music]
this worrisome idea isn't new it's been
around for a while but it saw a surge in
the headlines last month after a new
paper by Canadian researchers was
published with the somewhat frightening
title a viral spillover risk increases
with climate change in high Arctic Lake
sediments
whoa so is this yet another worry to add
to that long list of things to lose
sleep over well let's background it
first
um ice and Glaciers and permafrost acts
kind of like a a time capsule for for
any organic matter that's trapped in it
under the right conditions
that matter changes very little and and
very slowly including any microorganisms
or viruses in fact although heat
destroys most viruses freezing cold
doesn't affect them much at all many
bacteria also have long-lived forms that
could allow them to remain potentially
viable for a really long time after
freezing so
as polar ice melts could it release
pathogens that might prove dangerous to
us
sure it could in fact it already has we
think in recent history at least once
back in 2016 there was a sudden outbreak
of Anthrax among reindeer herders in a
remote corner of Siberia and scientists
think that it likely started when a
reindeer carcass Frozen in the
permafrost decades before thought out
and and subsequently infected living
animals which spread it to their herders
so so this kind of process can almost
certainly occur at least with pathogens
known to infect humans already
but it's a really big jump from that
event to conclude that nightmare
pathogens from the distant past are
going to begin thawing out and infecting
us
um that's because ancient microbes would
have been mostly specialized in hosts
that are often simply not around anymore
um so to eventually in fact us
they'd first have to find and adapt to
new hosts in the Arctic or Antarctic
parts of the world where there's just
not a lot of opportunity which is why
lots of experts continue to think
that the most likely place the next
pandemic pathogen will appear is
somewhere with high biodiversity and
lots of human animal interaction not
where the ice caps are melting my
takeaway from my reading is that you
can't rule out viral spell over there
completely especially with more and more
species moving North as as things heat
up but
the warmer parts of the planet are still
a much more likely place for viral
spillover to occur
than the cold parts are
and warmer climbs are where we're headed
for our next report especially during
the pandemic many in Kenya needed money
to stay above water and sustain their
businesses
they got together and collected for
loans which helped many people but
especially women to get through tough
times
[Music]
all right
is an informal Cooperative Society used
to pool and invest savings
it's common in East Africa and
especially popular in Kenya
this group of women from the mathari
area of Nairobi say that their Chalmers
saved their lives during the pandemic
all right
a group normally consists of 10 to 25
people
members Place their savings loan
repayments and other contributions on
the table
then they can borrow immediately with
short-term or long-term rates
this aoma belongs to a savings group
called swep
members meet twice a month and
contribute 20 Kenyan shillings per week
they'd already set some money aside
before covid-19 and once the pandemic
hit they used those funds to buy food to
be shared with the other families
most of the members are casual laborers
while the self-employed have also seen
their incomes dropping off in the last
two years
I joined a saving group where I took a
loan and opened my hotel business
that was new for me
but after a while I paid the loan back
and took another one and used it to buy
a small house
now I want to keep saving more money so
that I can upgrade it
foreign
savings groups help them boost their
loaning capacity
it wasn't easy to borrow money from
financial institutions during this time
as the interest on loans was high
plus they needed collateral which most
of the individuals did not have
the savings groups serve as collective
collateral with the members vouching for
each other
[Music]
during covid our savings group used to
get requests to make masks and PPE and
as we also teach tailoring in this group
we took on those orders we took a loan
from the Sako Co-op and we were able to
deliver and after we got paid we
returned the loan money
another big benefit is that through the
savings groups we were able to access
loans from the credit union
the money provided enables us to work on
tenders
when we take on orders for making soap
for example and also when we need money
for machines
shining hope for communities or Shopko
is one of the other organizations that
the groups have helped to attract
funding from
it provides grants and Loans to help
local traders in poor areas to recover
from the covert related slump
Shin introduces the women to the table
banking system and also trains them in
financial literacy
doesn't mean those efforts have enabled
the women to develop a joint saving
culture in the community
I'll tell you out of 15 000 members here
70 percent are women women are the most
powerful people in this community yes
and you know in terms of also businesses
we had women who are you know
preparing how do you call the illicit
Brew changa around right now they have
left those you know risky businesses and
they are into a proper and legal
businesses for the women the chance for
a new life
since the outbreak of the pandemic
experts around the world have grappled
with the question of how best to fight
the Coronavirus
what's the consensus on the best way to
treat SARS kovi 2. as with many other
diseases research remains ongoing here's
an overview of the methods developed so
far
early in the pandemic doctors and
healthcare workers desperately sought
ways to treat patients badly affected by
covert 19. life-saving interventions
included methods used to treat other
severe respiratory diseases among them
supplementary oxygen and artificial
ventilation
severe covid-19 is often caused by the
body's own immune system if it goes into
overdrive and begins attacking a
patient's own tissue it can be calmed by
anti-inflammatory drugs especially a
class of steroid-based medicines like
one called dexamethasone
as the pandemic progressed drug
developers focused on other ways to
treat the disease before it grew too
severe like the protective antibodies
produced by people who had survived an
encounter with covid-19 which latch onto
the virus to disable it using modern
techniques they can be copied and
produced on a large scale
these monoclonal antibodies or mabs
could be given to high-risk patients
early on
this could give a patient's immune
system more time to catch up before the
virus could replicate massively
spiraling out of control a final class
of medicines used to help prevent
infected patients from developing severe
disease is called antivirals they took
longer to develop but are now widely
available
antivirals work by interfering with
viral replication which in the end
lowers the number of viruses that are
produced
that also gives a patient's immune
system time to catch up in the race to
learn about the Invader and fight it off
before the illness can take a turn for
the worse
[Music]
we also talked to zandratzizek director
of The Institute of Medical virology at
the University Hospital Frankfurt and
professor of medical virology at the
Goethe University
antiviral drugs are her area of
expertise
[Music]
for a long time we focused on developing
vaccines to protect people from SARS
cov2
effective drug treatments took a back
seat is that still the case
yeah we now fortunately have a few
antiviral drugs that can also be
administered orally as a tablet one is
malnu piravir which inhibits enzymes in
the virus it inhibits the polymerase
activity that the virus needs to
replicate the other drug is a protease
inhibitor an enzyme that's the drug most
of us know under the brand name of
paxlovid
the drug that was used at the beginning
of the pandemic REM deserveer is now
being used more often again but it's a
drug that has to be administered
intravenously
the other issue is that all these drugs
are only effective if they're taken at
the beginning of the infection meaning
within five days of developing symptoms
after that we tend to turn to drugs that
modulate the immune system like
cortisone which many people have heard
of
steroids in other words
is drug development generally more
difficult than vaccine development and
how did that play out in the case of
SARS Co V2
yeah
we were lucky because we were able to
draw on what are called repurposed drugs
those are drugs that were developed for
other diseases or that had reached a
certain stage of development
is one example when it became apparent
that certain drugs were effective
against SARS cov2 that made it possible
to eliminate some stages in their
clinical development
that is drugs that already existed but
had not yet been given official
clearance
[Music]
you're also researching treatments
against SARS cov2 what approach are you
taking
we're pursuing a variety of approaches
for example there are weak spots on the
coronavirus that we're trying to Target
with enzymes and the same holds for the
points on the host cell that the virus
attaches to there's also what's called
high throughput screening which involves
screening huge chemical libraries
containing many thousands of substances
to see if you get a hit meaning it's
something that shows biological activity
you can also work in a targeted Way by
studying the virus and how it replicates
and identify targets
that could be a protein that the virus
needs to replicate for example which you
then try to Target
we've been pursuing various strategies
and have had some promising results
but they're all still in the early stage
of research
at the cell culture model stage did it
will take a long time before they're
ready to be tested in humans
so the pandemic might be over by then
we'll probably have reached a different
stage of things by then but SARS cov2
isn't going away there will always be
people who become seriously ill for
example people who are immunosuppressed
or elderly people some will still need
drug treatments five years or ten years
from now another strategy that we're
pursuing is that we're also trying to
develop what are called broad-spectrum
antivirals
those would be drugs that wouldn't be
limited to just a single virus like SARS
cov2 but might be effective against all
coronaviruses for example
we already know that coronaviruses have
the potential to lead to pandemics we've
seen it several times we want to act
prophylactically and be ready for the
future
that's why we're hoping that one day if
a SARS cov3 or MERS 2 becomes a problem
will already have an effective drug that
we can start using right away
Professor cesack thank you for the
interview thank you
the pandemic was also a very difficult
time for doctors
in our my covert section we meet one in
Colombia
the pandemic negatively impacted
everything the health system the economy
our mental health Society everybody was
affected
my name is Stella Navarro I'm an
intensive care physician in Medellin I
only realized by chance that I was
infected
I was working my shift I wasn't feeling
ill
I was eating dinner when I noticed that
I had no taste and I knew that's a
common covered symptom
I had an existing problem with my spinal
column and covered worsened the pain it
had to be treated I needed a nerve root
block
for covert patients being in intensive
care was psychologically challenging
the emotional impact was considerable
these people were already very
frightened
brutal and if you're in an ICU you know
the situation is serious and the fact
that no visitors were allowed made it
even worse
so all of us working in intensive care a
lot was lost but a lot was gained we
managed to pull through we did it but it
was a very hard situation A catastrophic
one there were moments of hopelessness
the experience was traumatic and had to
be processed
on a personal level we felt responsible
we weren't Heroes we were just doing our
job I don't know it was very exhausting
there's a sense now that we need to make
up for that time recover the time we
gave to all these people for ourselves
we're out of debt but I don't think it
will ever be paid back
[Music]
we hope we've managed to answer some of
your questions about the current
pandemic situation and what the path
forward may be
next week we'll take a closer look at
the phenomenon of long covert until then
goodbye and look after yourselves
foreign
[Music]